en el ejercicio anterior crea este ruido
perlín en 2d en una sola resolución pero
recuerda nuestra meta es la variación
multi resolución y hemos hecho eso ya
sumando dos curvas 2d y podemos sumar
superficies de la misma manera por
ejemplo imagina que tengo esta
superficie y la sumo con esta superficie
obtendríamos esta otra superficie
desarrollamos esta herramienta para
demostrar como mezclamos dos patrones 2d
con diferentes resoluciones empecemos
con un patrón de tablero de ajedrez aquí
lo tenemos en baja resolución en
resolución media y en alta resolución y
este es el resultado de unir todos esos
patrones y veo que agregaste un
deslizador de amplitud para definir qué
tanto contribuye cada resolución al
patrón final sí exactamente como antes y
también puedes ajustar el color base muy
bonito ahora cambiemos el tablero de
ajedrez por los patrones aleatorios que
usamos en el ejercicio anterior ahora
tenemos el poder para crear todo un
rango de resultados
de hecho creo que ya estamos listos para
usarlo en la pierna de dinosaurio manos
a la obra el programa final extiende lo
que aprendimos en la elección anterior
genera un diagrama de voronoi pero ahora
podemos definir el patrón aplicado a la
piel y a las escamas por separado y
divertido haré un ejemplo rápido en este
panel principal puedo ajustar el tamaño
de las escamas y también agregar y
eliminar zonas manualmente eso lo
estudiamos en la primera lección
ahora vamos a los controles de la piel
aquí puedes ajustar el color base y el
brillo y aquí tenemos tres deslizadores
uno para ajustar la amplitud del patrón
de baja resolución otro para la
resolución media y otro para la alta
resolución tenemos mucho con que jugar
para obtener la apariencia que buscamos
y los controles para las escamas
funcionan igual permitiéndonos crear un
aspecto para las escamas completamente
separado al de la piel observa que
tenemos dos colores base que podemos
seleccionar el color uno define el color
de las escamas pequeñas el color dos
define el color de las escamas más
grandes
entonces cualquier escama tomará un
color entre los dos colores base hicimos
lo mismo en la lección anterior
esto nos permite obtener variaciones de
color naturales entre amarillo y verde
que es lo que nos indicó día exacto y
cuando estés listo para poner a prueba
tu patrón puedes presionar aquí
renderizar en 3d en volver a tu panel en
forma de pierna para darte una idea del
aspecto final ya se ve bastante bien
pero aquí nos detenemos ahora es tu
turno de apoderarse de todos estos
controles y crear tu propia piel de
dinosaurio usando redoble de tambores
por favor multi resolución en 2d con
ruido de berlín trata de ver si puedes
construir el arte de referencia que nos
dio tía pero luego atrévete a ver qué
otras cosas se te ocurren en qué tipo de
cosas piensas cuando estás diseñando la
piel de tus personajes pensamos en
muchas cosas pero cuando diseñamos lo
abultado de cada una de las celdas
sentimos que si usamos una curva más
plana le da a la piel un aspecto como de
ser más usada
hacer una superficie más dura y por lo
tanto parece un personaje más viejo pero
si las celdas son más redondas da una
sensación de ser una piel más joven y
fresca
en el paquete de piel que terminamos
usamos una rampa desde el centro de la
celda hasta el borde y luego definimos
cuál era su curvatura porque notamos que
había una enorme diferencia entre tener
esa superficie plana y una curva
aleatoria y logramos definir
matemáticamente la curva usando los
patrones que teníamos dentro de cada una
de las celdas esta impresionante sí